In the month of Ramadan when the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam was
appointed as a prophet. And Gabrielis
came to him with those first
and most honorous words of the Quran
of
and the
transmission of the Quran and the
sending down of the Quran and the
descent of the Quran upon
the heart of our prophet sallall.aii
wasallam. first begin.
We had reached to the last portion when
received the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam after he was first told those
first five verses of surah.
And the prophet sallallah.aii alaihi
wasallam went home to Khadijah and after
she was able to calm him and after he
had regained his composure sai was
from the initial shock
he related to her what had happened
and what had occurred and
gave him some words of encouragement
and some words of motivation.
And then she took him to see someone
more knowledgeable than herself with
regards to these issues.
said
her name
she was the first
wife of the prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam and the
mother of all of his children
except for one of his children Ibraim
who he had from Mariel Kla
many years later in Medina. The
prophet sallallah.aii wasallam had eight
children, seven four four boys and
four girls. The scholars differ on the
number of children that he had.
mentions that the most correct opinion
in his book
in his of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam and also in his book alam
he mentions that the correct opinion is
that the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam had four boys and four girls
and that all of those children, seven of
which were from Khadijah
and Ibraim was his last and final child
that he had from Naria many years later
who passed away in his infancy. All of
the boys passed away in their infancy
and all of the girls passed away in his
lifetime except for Fatima
who passed away immediately after his
death 6 months later.
And so
she took the prophet sallallah.aii Wasam
to see her cousin
Noelbd.
His name was Ibel Abdul.
And
had accepted Christianity or we should
say accepted
and this was incredibly rare and
incredibly strange in the time of
amongst the Arabs of the Arab Peninsula.
You have to remember that Christianity
of the time was so incredibly and
radically different than what the pagan
Arabs were upon and worshiped. And so
those who accepted Christianity and even
more scarcely those who accepted Judaism
from amongst the Arabs of Jahia, this
was an incredibly rare phenomenon. And
Noel Allah accepted
Christianity in his time and not only
that but he had another very
another very unusual trait and that
is that he was literate and he wasn't
only literate but he was also bilingual
and in some narrations it's indicated
that he was triilingual he actually
spoke Arabic Hebrew Hebrew and Aramaic
and he was literate in all three of
those languages and he was a skilled
translator. And by the time the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam received his
message and by the time these words
of
along with the subsequent four verses
were revealed to him
was very very old. He was literally
and metaphorically at death's door. He
was at the very very end of his life and
he had also lost his vision. So he could
no longer see. He was a skilled
translator and he was responsible for
translating much of the gospel and much
of the Torah into from you know
Aramaic and Hebrew into Arabic for the
Arabs to be able to read of the time but
people didn't know how to read and they
were very very unacquainted
with
these religions and these books in
the time of Jahia.
And as a result, Warpa was
he was kind of it almost seemed like
he had fell kind of between the cracks
in amongst his own people because
they were upon the worship of idols. And
that was radically different in every
way from the adherence of to what
remnants he had of the religion of
Isaam.
And so Khadijah took the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam to why?
Because of his knowledge of scripture.
because of his knowledge of the history
of the prophets and messengers that
Allah had sent. And the Arabs believed
in those prophets and messengers. Just
because the Arabs worshiped idols didn't
mean that they didn't believe in the
prophets and messengers. They did. They
didn't believe in the hereafter. and
they had very much perverted the
religion and teachings of Ibraim and is
all having said that they still believed
that Ibraim was a prophet and a
messenger. They still believed that is a
messenger. They still believed that MS
was a messenger and that Isa was a
messenger. But they believed that these
were messengers to the people of the
book, not to them. For them it was
Ibraim and is those were the Arabs and
those were their messengers.
And so because of this
they believed that prophethood
you know in its general sense was not
only possible but did happen. They
believed in that. And so Khadijah
believed in the in in the prophets
and messengers in a general sense, a
very macro sense. She she believed that
Ibraimisam
was the messenger of Allah and that the
Cabba was the house of Allah and so
forth. And this is if you understand
this about the dynamic of their belief
and what little amounts of the teachings
of Ibraim that they still had, it will
be easier for you to understand the
environment and the very contradicting
beliefs
that the Arabs had, the par pagan
Arabs had in the time of the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam. So for instance,
you'll find that the pagan Arabs used to
fast ash
in Mecca. They used to fast ash. They're
not Jewish, right? The women used to
wear
used to cover themselves, wear some
kind, some semblance of hijab. They used
to cover their head and cover their
hair, right? They had some semblance of
modesty. they had some semblance of
omla. A lot of people
they read these things and they
wonder where did this come from? It came
from their mixed up belief
and what they believe to be the
teachings of Ibraim. But those teachings
were perverted by their various
chieftains
over time.
And Ibin Luhai, he is the one that first
introduced idolatry
into the Arab Peninsula. He went up to
Hashem for trade and Ibuhai was very
well regarded amongst the people of
Mecca and this is way before the
prophet's birth
and he used to go up there.
They used to go up there during the
winter months to buy and sell and
buy fruits and so forth or the summer
months. And the Romans had taken over
those areas, Hashem, Palestine and and
they had idols. They used to worship
idols and they had idols of their saints
as well. And so Ibuhai,
he saw this as being
really, really logical. You know, it
made sense to him. It really made sense.
you know, we're too sinful to go
directly to Allah. Who are we to worship
Allah directly? We have to we have to
get on the good side of the saints who
are more likely to accept us than Allah
because we are not pure enough to go
directly to Allah. Only the saints are
pure enough to go directly to Allah.
And so the saints of Allah
they are very close to Allah and they
are our middleman between us and Allah.
There are interceders.
They will intercede on our behalf. If we
want something, we don't ask Allah
directly. We ask our interceder. We ask
the saints so and so or the saints so
and so which later turned into
and later turned into the gods of the
Romans and some of the false idols of
the people of N even were still
worshiped in the Arab peninsula and the
prophet's time sai wasallam went up
there and he saw the Romans worshiping
these idols and they had these idols and
they portable, right? It gives you
something to focus on when you're
praying and it gives you something
tangible to interact with to interact
with. And so he brought them back. big
merchant, big chieftain introduced
idolatry to his to an entire generation
of people that he was responsible for
leading into the hellfire
based on what?
That's a good idea. And I'm a really
really smart guy. I mean, what's what's
the chances of me making a mistake with
something this? Look at how good I
am at buying and selling. Look at how
much I'm respected. Right? And that is
what innovation is. Innovation into the
way of the prophets and the messengers
and into their religion.
Lay is one of the only people that from
Jah that the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam saw
in the hellfire.
Iban Luhai Iban Luhai is one of the only
people from Jahyah who he saw
specifically in the hellfire when he was
shown the gates of hell. He saw in the
hellfire and the prophet sallallah.aii
alaihi wasallam said and he is the first
chieftain
of the Arabs to introduce them to the
worship of idols.
We will stop there for this evening.
We'll pick this up again tomorrow night
and finish it up.
Is that the language?